the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones house
of the dragon video all right my friends
in this video i want to do something a
little different in this first video i
will show you exactly what you will see
in house of the dragon as you all know
hbo is developing another game of
thrones show that will be set in
westeros only this show is based on
george rr martin's fire and blood vol 1.
in house of the dragon we will see what
happened during the dance of dragons
when house targaryen went to war against
its own family over the iron throne and
the line of succession almost all of the
information regarding these historical
events is written down in that first
volume of fire and blood this is what
hbo is adapting into house of the dragon
so what i will do is read what it says
word for word about the dance of dragons
that way you will know what's about to
happen in this new game of thrones
series now when house of the dragon
begins we will see king viserys
targaryen sitting on the iron throne he
will most likely be the face of the show
during its first season however this
will not last for very long although
viserys was the king of westeros house
of the dragon really isn't about him the
show will focus on all of the insanity
that happens after he dies when his
family fights over who should be seated
on the iron throne next as i have said
before this will be very similar to what
we saw in the first season of game of
thrones like robert baratheon when king
viserys dies his wife alison hightower
will ensure that their son aegon sits on
the iron throne next instead of his
eldest daughter rhaenyra who he named as
his rightful heir
now viserys did have a brother named
daemon and although he did love him he
did not want him sitting on the iron
throne after he was gone this is one of
the reasons why viserys eventually named
his daughter rhaenyra targaryen as the
next heir for the iron throne and for a
while it seemed like this is exactly
what would happen only that was until
viserys met his second wife alison
hightower king viserys and alicent end
up having several children together
including their sons aegon and aemond
now you would think since viserys now
had a son he would just make him his
heir but that doesn't happen although he
now had sons with al ascent he still
made sure his eldest daughter rhaenyra
stayed next in line for the iron throne
and this is where the major issue lies
because as soon as viserys dies all of
this goes right out of the window like
cersei lannister alison sets her son on
the iron throne before anyone else even
knows what's happening and as you can
imagine this leads to an all-out war
among south targaryen now let me read
what george rr martin has written down
in fire and blood like i said earlier
hbo will be adapting everything from
fire and blood in regards to what
happened during the dance of dragons so
we should see all of this happen in the
show when it eventually does release
later this year the name of this chapter
is the dying of dragons the blacks and
the greens it says the dance of dragons
is the flowery name given to the savage
struggle for the iron throne of westeros
fought between two rival branches of
house targaryen during the years 129 to
131 ac
to characterize the dark turbulent
bloody doings of this era as a dance
strikes us as grotesquely inappropriate
no doubt the phrase was originated by
some singer the dying of the dragons
would have been a much more fitting name
now there were two principal claimants
to the iron throne upon the death of
king viserys targaryen the first was his
daughter rhaenyra the only surviving
child of his first marriage the second
was aegon his eldest son by his second
wife amidst the chaos and carnage
brought on by their rivalry other
would-be kings would stake claims as
well only to fall as swiftly as they had
arisen the dan split the seven kingdoms
in two as lords knights and small folk
declared for one side or the other and
raised up arms against one another even
house targaryen itself was divided over
the two years of struggle a terrible
toll was taken on the great lords of
westeros together with their bannermen
knights and small folk while the dynasty
survived the end of the fighting saw
targaryen power much diminished and the
world's last dragons vastly reduced in
number the dance was a war unlike any
other ever fought in the long history of
the seven kingdoms though armies marched
and met in savage battle much of the
slaughter happened on water and
especially in the air as dragon fought
dragon it was a war marked by stealth
murder and betrayal as well a war fought
in the shadows and stairwells council
chambers and castle yards with knives
and lies and poison long simmering the
conflict burst into the open on the
third day of the third moon of 129 ac
when the ailing bed-ridden king viserys
targaryen closed his eyes for a nap in
the red keep of king's landing and died
without waking his body was discovered
by a serving man at the hour of the bat
when it was the king's custom to take a
cup of hippocrats that servant ran to
inform queen alisen whose apartments
were on the floor below the kings
septenu stace writing on these events
some years later mentions that the
manservant delivered his dire message
directly to the queen and her alone
without raising a general alarm ustase
does not believe this was wholly
fortuitous the king's death had been
expected for some time he argues and
queen allison and her party the
so-called greens had taken care to
instruct all of viserys's guards and
servants and what to do when the time
came the dwarf mushroom suggests a more
sinister scenario whereby queen alice
sent hurried king viserys on his way
with a dash of poison in his hippocrats
it must be noted that mushroom was not
in king's landing the night that he died
but rather on dragonstone in service
with rhaenyra targaryen queen alicent
went at once to the king's bedchamber
followed by sir kristen cole the lore
commander of the kingsguard once they
had confirmed viserys was dead her grace
ordered his room sealed and watched
under strict guard the serving man who
had found the king's body was taken into
custody to make certain he did not
spread the tale
sir kristin returned to the white sword
tower and sent his brothers of the
kingsguard to summon the members of the
king's small council it was the hour of
the owl then as now the sworn
brotherhood of the kingsguard consisted
of seven knights men who had taken
solomows to devote their lives to
defending the king and his kin
only five of the white cloaks were in
king's landing at the time of viserys's
death sir kristin cole himself sir eric
cargill sir rickard thorne sir stephen
darklin and sir willis fell
sir eric cargill and sir laurent marbran
was with princess rhaenyra on
dragonstone they remained unaware and
uninvolved as their brother-in-arms went
forth into the night to rouse the
members of the small council from their
beds the council convened in the queen's
apartments within maegor's holdfest many
accounts have come down to us of what
was said and done that night by far the
most detailed and accurate of them is
grand maester munkins the dance of
dragons a true telling though monken's
exhaustive history was not written until
a generation later and drew on many
different sorts of materials including
maester's chronicles memoirs steward's
records and interviews with 147
surviving witnesses to the great events
of these times his accounts of the inner
workings of the court relies upon the
confessions of grand maester or weil as
set down before his execution unlike
mushroom and septinus stace whose
versions derive from rumors hearsay and
family legend the grand maester was
there at the meeting and assisted in the
council's deliberations and decisions
though it must be recognized that at the
time he wrote or while was most anxious
to show himself in a favorable light and
absolve himself of any blame for what
was to follow
gathering in the queen's chambers as the
body of her lord husband grew cold above
where queen alice sent herself her
father serado hightower handed the king
sir kristin cole lord commander of the
kingsguard grand maester or wild
lord lyman beesberry master of coin a
man of 80 sir tylen lannister master of
ships brother to the lord of casterly
rock larry strong called laris clubfoot
lord of harrenhal master of whisperers
and lord jasper wilde called iron rod
master of laws grand maester monken dubs
this gathering the green's council in
his true telling grand maester or weil
opened the meeting he said septenu's
stay should be summoned to perform the
last rites and pray for the king's soul
a raven must needs to be sent to
dragonstone at once to inform rhaenyra
of her father's death mayhaps her grace
the queen would care to write the
message so as to soften the sad news
with some words of condolence
the bells are always wrong to announce
the death of a king someone should see
to that and of course we must begin to
make our preparations for queen
rhaenyra's coronation serato hightower
cut him off
all this must needs weight he declared
until the question of succession is
settled as the king's hand he was
empowered to speak with the king's voice
even to sit the iron throne in the
king's absence viserys had granted him
the authority to rule over the seven
kingdoms and until such time as our new
king is crowned that rule would continue
until our new queen is crowned someone
said in grand maester monken's account
the words are or wiles spoken softly no
more than a quibble however mushroom and
septinus stace insists that it was lord
beesberry who spoke up and in a waspish
tone king insisted queen of ascent the
iron throne by rights must go to his
gracious eldest son the discussion that
followed lasted until dawn grand maester
monken tells us mushroom and septinus
stace agree in their accounts only lord
beesberry spoke on behalf of princess
rhaenyra targaryen the ancient master of
coin who had served king viserys for the
majority of his reign and his
grandfather jiharis the old king before
him reminded the council that rhaenyra
was older than her brothers and had more
targaryen blood that the late king had
chosen her as his successor that he had
reportedly refused to alter the
succession despite the pleadings of
queen alicent and her greens that
hundreds of lords and landed knights had
sworn solomos to defend her rights but
these words fell on ears made of stone
sir tylen lannister mentioned that many
of the lords who had sworn to defend the
succession of rhaenyra were long dead it
had been 24 years he said i had sworn no
such oath serrato hightower reminded
them that rhaenyra's husband was none
other than prince daemon targaryen and
he said we all know that one's nature
make no mistake should rhaenyra ever sit
the iron throne it will be lord flea
bottom who rules us a king consort as
cruel and unforgiving as maegor ever was
my own head will be the first one cut
off i do not doubt but your queen my
daughter will soon follow daemon will
find some pretext to put them all to
death one of these strongs put out
aemon's eye never forget he was a boy eh
but the boy is the father to the man and
bastards are monstrous by nature sir
kristen cole spoke up should the
princess reign he reminded them jacarys
velaryon would rule after her
seven save this realm if we see a
bastard on the iron throne he spoke of
rhaenyra's wanton ways and the infamy of
her husband they will make sure the red
keep becomes a brothel no man's daughter
will be safe nor any man's wife even the
boys we know what lenore was it is not
recorded that lord lara strong spoke a
word during this debate but that was not
unusual
if we do this grain maester or weil
cautioned the council according to the
true telling it must surely lead to war
rhaenyra will not meekly stand aside and
she has dragons
and friends lord beesberry declared men
of honor who will not forget the vows
they swore to her and her father
i am an old man but not so old that i
will sit here meekly while the likes of
you plot to steal her crown and so
saying he rose to go as to what happened
next the sources differ
grand maester or wild tells us that lord
beesberry was seized at the door by the
command of serado hightower and escorted
to the dungeons confined to a black cell
he would in time die of a chill while
awaiting trial septinus stace tells it
elsewise in his account sir kristin cole
forced lord beesberry back into his seat
and opened his throat with a dagger
mushroom charges sir kristen with his
lordship's death as well but in his
version cole grabbed the old man by the
back of his collar and flung him out a
window to die impaled upon the iron
spikes and the dry moat below the first
blood was shed in the dance of dragons
belonged to lord lyman bees berry master
of coin and lord treasurer of the seven
kingdoms no further dissent was heard
after the death of lord beesberry the
rest of the night was spent making plans
for the new king's coronation it must be
done fast all agreed and they must make
a list of all their allies and enemies
should rhaenyra targaryen refuse to
accept king aegon's ascension with
rhaenyra in confinement on dragonstone
about to give birth queen alice sends
green's enjoyed an advantage the longer
rhaenyra remained ignorant of the king's
death the slower she would be to move
mayhaps the [ __ ] will die in childbirth
queen alison is reported to have said
according to mushroom no ravens flew
that night no bells rang
those servants who knew of the king's
death were sent to the dungeons sir
kristin cole was given the task of
taking into custody such blacks has
remained at court those lords and
knights who might be inclined to favor
princess rhaenyra do them no violence
unless they resist serado hightower
commanded such men as bending and swear
filthy to king aegon shall suffer no
harm at our hands and those who will not
ask grand maester or while or traitors
said iron rod and must die at traitor's
death dawn was breaking over the city
before queen alicent sent the kingsguard
to bring her sons aegon and aemon to the
council the one-eyed prince aemon 19 was
found in the armory donning plate and
mail for his morning routine in the
castle yard is aegon king he asked sir
willis fell or must we kneel and kiss
the old horse cunny
princess helena was breaking her fast
with her children when the kingsguard
came to her but when asked of the
whereabouts of aegon her brother and
husband she only said he is not in my
bed you may be sure
aegon was at his revels monken says in
his true telling vaguely the testimony
of mushroom claims sir kristen cole
found the young king to be drunk and
naked in a flea bottom rat pit where two
gutter snipes with foul teeth were
biting and tearing at each other for his
amusement while a girl who could not
have been more than 12 pleasured his
member with her mouth however septaneu
stace insists that the girl aegon was
with was actually the daughter of a
wealthy traitor and well cared for
besides aegon at first refused to be a
part of his mother's schemes my sister
is the heir not me he says in september
stasis accounts only when sir kristin
cole convinced him that rhaenyra must
surely execute him and his brother
should she don the crown did aegon waver
while any true born targaryen yet lives
no strong can ever hope to sit the iron
throne cole said rhaenyra has no choice
but to take your heads if she wishes her
bastards to rule after her it was this
and only this that convinced aegon to
accept the crown that the small council
was offering him while the knights of
the kingsguard were seeking after queen
alison's sons other messengers summoned
the commander of the city watch and his
captains to the red key there were seven
of them each commanding one of the city
gates five of them were judged
sympathetic to aegon's cause when
questioned the other two along with
their commander were deemed
untrustworthy and found themselves in
chains sir luthor largent the most
fearsome of the five was made the new
commander of the gold cloaks serado
hightower being a prudent man however he
took care to name his own son sir wayne
hightower the queen's brother as large
and second instructing him to keep a
wary eye on sir luthor for any signs of
disloyalty sir tylen lannister was named
master of coin in place of the late lord
beasbury and acted at once to seize the
royal treasury the crown's gold was
divided into four one of them was
entrusted to the care of the iron bank
of braavos for safe keeping another sent
under strong guard to casterly rock a
third to old town the remaining wealth
was to be used for bribes and gifts and
to hire sell swords if needed to take
sir tylen's spot as master of ships
serato looked to the iron islands
sending a raven to dalton greyjoy the
red kraken the daring and bloodthirsty
16 year old lord reaper of pike offering
him a seat on the council for his
allegiance a day went by then another
neither septons nor silent sisters were
summoned to the bedchamber where king
viserys lay swollen and rotting no bells
rang ravens flew but not the dragonstone
they instead went to old town to
casterly rock to river run to high
garden and to many other lords and
knights whom queen alicent had caused to
think might be sympathetic to her son
the annals of the great council of 101
were brought forth and examined and note
was made of which lords had spoken for
viserys in which for rainey's lana or
lehnor the lords assembled had favored
the male claimant over the female by 20
to one but there had been dissenters and
those same houses were most like to lend
rhaenyra their support should it come to
war
rhaenyra would have the sea snake in his
fleet serato judged and like as not the
other lords of the eastern shores as
well lords bar emmon macy zeldagar and
crab most like maybe even even star all
were lesser houses safe for the valerons
the northmen were a greater concern
winterfell had spoken for raineys at
harrenhal as had lord stark's bannermen
dustin of borrowtown and manderly of
white harbor nor could house aaron be
relied on for the eerie was ruled by
woman lady jane the maiden of the veil
whose own rights might be called into
question should rhaenyra targaryen be
set aside the greater danger was deemed
to be storm's end for house baratheon
had always been staunch in support of
the claims of princess rhaenys and her
children though old lord borman had died
his son boros was even more belligerent
than his father and the lesser
stormlords would surely follow wherever
he led
then we must see that he leads them to
our king queen alicent declared
whereupon she sent for her second son
thus it was not a raven that took flight
for storm's end that day but vegar
oldest and largest of the dragons of
westeros on her back wrote amon
targaryen with a sapphire in the spot of
his missing eye your sole job is to win
the hand of one of lord baratheon's
daughters his grandsire serato told him
before he flew any of the four will do
woo her and wet her and lord boros will
deliver the stormlands for your brother
now if you fail i will not fail aim on
blustered aegon will have storm's end
and i will have this girl by the time
prince aemon left king's landing the
stink from the dead king's bedchamber
had wafted all through maegor's holdfest
and many while tales and rumors were
spreading through the cord and castle
the dungeons under the red keep had
swallowed up so many men suspected of
disloyalty that even the high septon had
begun to wonder at these disappearances
serato hightower as methodical a man has
ever served as han wanted more time to
make preparations however queen alicent
knew that they could delay no longer
aegon was already growing weary of
secrecy am i a king or no he demanded of
his mother if i am a king then crown me
the bells begin to ring on the tenth day
of the third moon of 129 ac announcing
the end of a reign
grand maester or wow was at last allowed
to send his ravens and the black birds
took to the air by the hundreds
spreading the word of aegon's ascension
to every far corner of the realm the
silent sisters were sent for to ready
viserys dead body for burning and riders
went forth on white horses to spread the
war to the citizens of king's landing
hearing the cries monken writes some
wept while others cheered but most of
the small folks stared in silence
confused and wary and now and again a
voice cried out long live our queen
meanwhile hurried preparations were made
for the coronation the dragon pit was
chosen as the site under its mighty dome
were stone benches sufficient to seat 80
000 and the thick walls strong roof and
towering bronze doors made it defensible
should traders attempt to disrupt the
ceremony on the appointed day sir
christian cole set the iron and ruby
crown of aegon the conqueror on the brow
of the eldest son of king viserys and
queen alisen his mother alice sent
beloved of the small folk set her own
crown on the head of her daughter helena
aegon's wife and sister after kissing
her cheeks the mother knelt before the
daughter bowed her head and said my
queen
how many came to see the crowning
remains a matter of debate grand maester
monken drawing upon or a while tells us
that more than a hundred thousand small
folk jammed into the dragon pit their
cheer so loud they shook the very walls
while mushroom says the stone benches
were half filled with the high sept in
an old town too old and frail to journey
to king's landing it fell to septenue
stace to anoint king aegon's brow with
holy oils and bless him in the seven
names of god a few of those in
attendance was sharper eyes than most
might have noticed that there were about
four white cloaks in attendance on the
new king not five aegon had suffered his
first affections the night before when
sir stefan darklin of the kingsguard had
slipped from the city with esquire
stewards and four guardsmen under the
cover of darkness they made their way
out a gate to where a fisherman's skiff
awaited to take them to dragonstone
they brought with them a stolen crown a
band of yellow gold ornamented with
seven gems of different colors this was
the crown king viserys had worn and the
old king jeharis before him when aegon
had decided to wear the iron and ruby
crown of his namesake allison had
ordered viserys's crown locked away but
the steward made off with it instead
after the coronation the remaining
kingsguard escorted aegon to his mount a
splendid creature with gleaming golden
scales and pink wing membranes sunfire
was the name given this dragon of the
golden dawn monken tells us the king
flew thrice around the city before
landing inside the walls of the red key
sir arik cargill led his grace into the
throne room where aegon mounted the
steps of the iron throne before a
thousand lords and nights shouts rang
through the hall on dragonstone no
cheers were heard instead screams echoed
through the halls and stairwells saw the
sea dragon tower down from the queen's
apartments where rhaenyra targaryen
strained and shuddered in her third day
of labor the child had not been due for
another turn of the moon but the news
from king's landing had driven rhaenyra
into a black fury and her rage seemed to
bring on the birth as if the babe inside
her were angry as well and fighting to
get out rhaenara shrieked curses all
through her labor calling down the wrath
of the gods upon her half-brothers and
their mother the queen and detailing the
violence she would have flicked upon
them before she would let them die
she cursed the child inside her as well
mushroom tells us scratching at her
swollen belly as maester gerardus and
her midwife tried to restrain her and
shouting monster monster get out get out
get out when the baby finally did come
forth it was indeed a monster a
stillborn girl malformed with a hole in
her chest where her heart should have
been in a stubby scale tail or so
mushroom describes her the dwarf says it
was he who carried the little thing to
the yard for burning the dead girl had
been named visenya rhaenyra announced
the next day one milk of the poppy had
blunted the edge of her suffering she
was my only daughter and they killed her
they stole my crown and murdered my
daughter and they shall answer for it
and so the dance of the dragons began as
the princess rhaenyra targaryen called a
council of her own the black council the
true telling names that gathering on
dragonstone setting it against the green
council of king's landing rhaenara
herself attended seated right in the
middle of her uncle and husband prince
daemon targaryen and her trusted
counselor maester gerardus
her three sons were there with them
though none had reached the age of
manhood jace was 14 luke 13 and joffrey
was only 11. kingsguard stood with them
sir eric cargill twin brother of sir
eric cargill and the western men sir
laurent marbrand 30 knights 100
crossbowmen and 300 men in arms made up
the rest of dragonstone's garrison a
dozen lesser lords bannermen and vassals
to dragonstone set at the black council
as well
celtagar of claw isle staunton of rook's
rest massey of stone dance bar emmon of
sharp point in darkland of duskendale
amongst them but the greatest lord to
add his strength to rhaenyra was lord
corliss velaryon of driftmark with lord
corliss came his wife princess rhaenys 5
and 50. her face lean and lined her
black hair streaked with white yet
fierce and fearless as she had been at a
much younger age the queen who never was
mushroom calls her those who said at the
black council counted themselves as
loyal but knew full well that king aegon
would name them traitors each had
already received a summons from king's
landing demanding they show themselves
at the red keep to swear oaths of
loyalty to the new king all their hosts
combined could not match the strength
the hightowers alone could field aegon's
greens enjoyed other advantages as well
old town king's landing and lana's port
were the largest and richest cities in
the realm all three were held by
alison's greens every visible symbol of
legitimacy was aegon's he set the iron
throne he lived in the red keep he wore
the conqueror's crown wielded the
conqueror's sword and had been anointed
by a septon of the faith before the eyes
of tens of thousands grand maester
orwell set in his councils and the lord
commander of the kingsguard had set the
crown upon his head and he was male
which in the eyes of many made him the
rightful king his half-sister the
usurper against all that rhaenyra's
advantages were few some older lords
might yet recall the oaths they had
sworn when she was made princess of
dragonstone and named her father's heir
there had been a time when she had been
well loved by highborne and commons
alike when they had cheered her as the
realm's delight many a young lord and
noble knight had sought her favor then
though how many would still fight for
her now that she was a woman wed her
body aged and thickened by six
childbirths was a question none could
answer though her half-brother had
looted their father's treasury rhaenyra
had at her disposal the wealth of house
valeron and the sea snake's fleets gave
her superiority at sea and her consort
daemon targaryen tried and tempered in
the stepstones had more experience of
warfare than all their foes combined
last but far from least rhaenara had her
dragons as does aegon maester gerardus
mentions we have more said rhaenys the
queen who never was who had been a
dragon rider longer than all of them and
ours are larger and stronger but for
vegar dragons thrive best here on
dragonstone king aegon had his sunfire a
splendid beast though young aemond one
eye rode veigar helena's mount was dream
fire the she-dragon who had once born
the old king's sister rayna through the
clouds darun's dragon was tessarion with
her wings as dark as cobalt and her
claws and crest and belly scales as brey
has beaten copper that makes four
dragons a fighting size said rhaenys
helena's children had their own dragons
too but no more than hatchlings the
usurper's youngest son maelor only had
an egg against that prince daemon had
caraxes and rhaenyra had cyrax both
dragons were massive and formidable in
the air coraxis especially was fearsome
and no stranger to blood and fire after
the stepstones
three sons by lenore valeron were all
dragon riders vermax iraq's and tyraxis
were thriving and growing larger every
year aegon the younger eldest of
rhaenyra's sons by daemon commanded the
young dragon storm cloud though he had
yet to mount him his little brother
viserys went everywhere with his egg
rainey's own she-dragon melees the red
queen had grown lazy but remained
fearsome when roused daemon's children
by lena valeron might yet be dragon
riders too bayley's dragon the slender
green moon dancer would soon be large
enough to bare the girl on her back and
though her sister raina's egg had
hatched a broken thing that died within
hours of emerging from the egg cyrax had
recently laid more dragon eggs
one of her eggs had been given to reina
and it was said that the girl slept with
it every night and hoped for a dragon to
match her sisters six other dragons made
their layers in the smoky caverns of the
dragon mon above the castle
there was silver wing good queen
alisain's mount of old sea smoke the
green beast that had been the pride and
passion of sir lanor valeron old
vermithor unridden since the death of
king jaehaerys and behind the mountain
dwelled three wild dragons never claimed
nor ridden by any man living or dead the
small folk had named them sheep stealer
grey ghost and the cannibal find riders
to master silver wing vermithor and sea
smoke and we will have 9 dragons against
aegon's 4. mount and fly their wild kin
and we will have a dozen even without
storm clouds said renera that is how we
shall win this war lord zeldagar and
staunton agreed aegon the conqueror and
his sister showed everyone that knights
and armies could not stand against fire
and blood
celtagar urged rhaenara to fly against
king's landing at once and reduce the
city to ash and bone in how will that
serve us my lord the sea snake demanded
of him we want to rule the city not burn
it to the ground it will never come to
that zeldagar insisted the usurper will
have no choice but to oppose us with his
own dragons
r-9 must surely overwhelm his four at
what cost rhaenyra wondered my sons
would be riding three of those dragons i
remind you and it would not be nine
against four i will not be strong enough
to fly for some time yet and who is to
ride silver wing vermithorn sea smoke
you my lord i hardly think so it will be
five against four and one of their four
will be vegar that is no advantage
surprisingly daemon agreed with his wife
in the stepstones my enemies learned to
run and hide when they saw karaxi's
wings or heard him coming but they had
no dragons of their own it is no easy
thing for a man to be a dragon slayer
but the dragons can kill dragons and
they have any maester who has ever
studied the history of valyria can tell
you that i will not throw our dragons
against aegons unless i have no other
choice there are other ways to use them
better ways then daemon laid his own
strategies before the black council
rhaenyra must have a coronation of her
own to answer aegon's afterward they
would send out ravens calling on the
lords of the seven kingdoms to declare
their allegiance to their true queen we
must fight this war with words before we
go to battle daemon declared the lords
of the great houses held the key to
victory daemon insisted their bannermen
and vassals would follow where they lead
aegon the usurper had won the allegiance
of the lannisters of casterly rock and
lord tyrell of highgarden was a mewling
boy and swaddling clothes whose mother
acting as his regent would most like
align the reach with her over mighty
bannermen the high towers but the rest
of the realms great lords had yet to
declare storm's end will stand with us
princess rainey said she herself was of
that blood on her mother's side and the
late lord boreman had always been the
staunchest of friends daemon had good
reason to hope that the maid of the vale
might bring the eerie to their side as
well aegon would surely seek the support
of the iron islands he judged only with
the support of the iron islands could
aegon hope to exceed the strength of
house valeron at sea however the iron
men were notoriously fickle and dalton
greyjoy loved blood in battle he might
easily join sides with rhaenyra instead
the north was too remote to be of much
help in the fight the council judged by
the time the starks gathered their
banners and marched south the war might
well be over which left only the
riverlords we have friends in the
riverlands daemon said though not all of
them dare show their colors yet we need
somewhere they can gather a toehold on
the mainland large enough to house a
sizeable host and strong enough to hold
against whatever forces aegon can send
against us he showed the lords a map
here harrenhal daemon would lead the
assault on harrenhal riding karaxis
rhaenyra would remain at dragonstone
until she had recovered her strength the
valeron fleet would close off the gaulet
sallying fourth from dragonstone and
driftmark to block all shipping entering
or leaving blackwater bay we do not have
the strength to take king's landing by
storm damon said no more than our foes
could hope to capture dragonstone
the sea snake would command the fleet
while his wife rhaenys flew overhead to
keep their foes from attacking their
ships with dragons ravens would fly to
the riverrun the erie the iron islands
and storm's end to gain the allegiance
of their lords then up spoke rhaenyra's
eldest son jacarys we should bear those
messages he said
dragons will win the lords over faster
than ravens his brother lucario's agreed
insisting that he and jace were men or
near enough to make no matter our uncle
calls us strongs but when the lord see
us on dragon back they will know that
for a lie only targaryens ride dragons
mushroom tells us that the sea snake
grumbled at this insisting that the
three boys were valerons yet he smiled
as he said it even young joffrey chimed
in offering to mount his own dragon
tyraxes and join his brothers
rhaenyra forbade that joff was butt
eleven but jacarys was 14 lucario's 13
bold and handsome lads skilled in arms
who had long served as squires
if you go you go as messengers not as
knights she told them you will not
engage in any other fighting it was
decided that jace being the eldest son
would take the longer more dangerous
flight flying first to the erie to treat
with the lady of the veil then to white
harbor to win over lord manderly and
lastly to winterfell to meet with lord
stark luke's mission would be shorter
and safer he was to fly to storm's end
where it was expected that boros
baratheon would give him a warm welcome
a hasty coronation was held the next day
the arrival of sir stephen darklin late
of aegon's kingsguard was an occasion of
much joy on dragonstone especially when
it was learned that he and his fellow
loyalists had brought the stolen crown
of king jiharis with them 300 sets of
eyes looked on as daemon targaryen set
the old king's crown on the head of his
wife queen of the andals the rhoynar and
the first men daemon claimed for himself
the style protector of the realm anne
rhaenyra named herrell to son jacarys
the prince of dragonstone and heir to
the iron throne her first act as queen
was to declare sir otto hightower and
queen alicent traitors and rebels as for
my half-brothers and my sweet sister
helena she announced they had been led
astray by the council of evil men let
them come to dragonstone bend the knee
and ask my forgiveness and i shall
gladly spare their lives and take them
back into my heart and no man or woman
is as accursed as the kinslayer word of
rinera's coronation reached the red keep
the next day to the great displeasure of
king aegon my half-sister and my uncle
are guilty of high treason the young
king declared i want them attained i
want them arrested and i want them dead
cooler heads on the green council wish
to parlay rhaenyra must be made to see
that her cause is hopeless grand maester
or wild said
brother should not war against sister
send me to her that way we may talk and
reach an amicable accord aegon would not
hear of it septinus stace tells us that
his grace accused the grand maester of
disloyalty and spoke of having him
thrown into a black cell with his black
friends but the two queens his mother
queen alicent and his wife queen helena
spoke in favor of orwell's proposal the
truculent king gave way reluctantly so
grain maester or weil was dispatched
across the blackwater bay under a peace
banner along with a score of scribes and
septons amongst them ustays the terms
offered by the king were generous monken
declares in his true telling if rhaenyra
would acknowledge him as king before the
iron throne aegon would confirm her in
her possession of dragonstone and allow
the island and castle to pass to her son
jacarys after her death
her second son luceres would be
recognized as the rightful heir to drift
mark and the lands and holdings of house
valeron her boys by daemon aegon the
younger and viserys would be given
places of honor at court the former as
the king squire the latter as his
cupbearer
pardons would be granted to those lords
and knights who had conspired
treasonally with her against their true
king rhaenyra heard these terms in stony
silence then asked orowhile if he
remembered her father king viceros of
course your grace the maester answered
maybe you can tell us who he named as
his heir and successor the queen said
her crown upon her head
you your grace or wile responded
and rhaenyra nodded and said with your
own tongue you admit that i am your
lawful queen
why do you then serve my half-brother
the pretender monken tells us that
orwell gave along and a rudent reply
citing ando law and the great council of
101. mushroom claims he stammered and
voided his bladder whichever is true his
answer did not satisfy rhaenyra a grand
maester should know the law and serve it
she told her a while you are no grand
maester and you bring only shame and
dishonor to that chain you wear
rhaenyra's knights then stripped his
chain of office from his neck and forced
him to his knees while the princess
bestowed the chain upon her own man
maester gerardus a true and loyal
servant of the realm and its laws as she
sent her a while and the other envoys on
their way rhaenyra said tell my
half-brother that i will have my throne
or i will have his head
long after the dance was done the singer
lucion would compose a sad ballad called
farewell my brother still sung today the
song relates the last meeting between
sir eric cargill and his brother sir
cargill as or while zonvoy was boarding
the ship that would carry them back to
king's landing sir arik had sworn his
sword to aegon sir eric to rhaenyra in
the song each brother tries to convince
the other to switch sides failing they
exchange declarations of love
as they leave they know when they next
meet each other it will be as enemies
king aegon the second of his name was 2
and 20 quick to anger and slow to
forgive rhaenyra's refusal to accept his
rule enraged him i offered her an
honorable peace and the horse spat in my
face he declared what happens next is on
her own head
what happened next was war
[Music]
[Music]
you